attention will get you everything you
want you want to sell a course attention
you want to sell a t-shirt attention you
want to be the mayor of this town
attention you want to raise some money
for your nonprofit because you're
passionate about it attention you want
to be an actor attention attention is
the number one
asset attention it is the only asset
that everyone in here must Chase to
produce what they want being
unemotional about where the attention is
is very important too many of you have
demonized platforms out of your
subjective opinion a bad
experience and we must get over that
hump once you sit in this room and
understand that everything you want to
happen is about building brand and sales
in social networks then you start having
to get good at
it
my big question is a lot intellectually
know that we have a lot of super super
smart people in the industry even on
board level but why don't they act and
what would you help them on on or
arguing guys you need to act on social
media and now and even on Tik Tok brand
always outpaces sales that's
it so what do you mean with that um
because the next question people ask
when they say okay maybe 20 million
views a month isn't too bad for a
country with 80 million uh visitor
people that live there um when do we
make money with
it well I ask them when they make money
when they run a commercial for
$150,000 you would love you you know you
always make money when you have brand
Nike doesn't knock on your door in sales
to you you know it to me brand over
everything and the same way that you
know again Robin this is the same old
argument making content on LinkedIn
every day is far more effective than
buying a booth at a conference or buying
a full- page ad in a B2B magazine yet
because they've been buying booths at
conferences or buying B2B magazine print
for 40 years they think it works but
they don't think LinkedIn content or Tik
Tok works I I understand this I just you
know I'll be honest with you Robin I'm
not in the business of convincing people
yeah I'm not I'm not in the business of
convincing people I'm in the business of
putting out my thoughts to be
historically correct to build my own
brand so that people believe what I'm
saying has more weight as my career with
my gray hairs keeps going up that's it
so for me what do I say to people I say
this is what I believe is happening it's
been very obvious that this is what's
been happening for 20 years and if
you're not interested in adjusting to it
I think that's at the detriment of
building your business and how do you
make money when people know who you are
and what you sell they end up doing
business with you and this is brand
building I don't know what else to tell
you let me give you an example of a real
estate or a mortgage professional that
is all day long one of the most clever
moves everyone can do here you start a
podcast around the town you do business
in and now you're reaching out to people
that you want to do business with and
instead of trying to sell to them you
tell the rich dentist in your town hey
you're a pretty amazing dentist you want
to be on my podcast to tell people about
your Dentistry
now you've just turned a sales pitch and
not into a sales pitch but now you're
giving the dentist a platform now that
dude's com to your [__] house now
you're [__] friends now you get the
[__]
business that's a good idea and by the
way let me tell you about humans they've
all got egos even though nobody's
listening to your podcast nobody asked
that dentist to ever be on a podcast
before and he's [__]
[Music]
pumped as a DTC e-commerce brand yes at
kind of a most purchased price point how
much $30 to $50 pet up brand like it
okay so as that brand what paid
advertising platform would you target
before others if you were just choose
that Facebook number one which is crazy
right but like the way you asked the
question right like I only have so much
money like your biggest upside probably
Tik Tok but Tik Tok ad product is not as
refined as Facebook right now for DTC
and there's enough vulnerability there
that I'm not sure you know how to make
the content for Tik Tok What made
everybody win in DTC with Facebook is
you didn't have to make good content
Facebook was so [__] effective the
math worked for everyone they didn't
realize they were doing crappy ads it
just worked cuz the media was so goddamn
underpriced and people like big
companies would rather do a million
dollars doing TV commercial that none of
you would watch then put into Facebook
and that's where the ARB was so I still
think it's Facebook believe it or not
but I would say that if you feel in your
heart or your stomach you understand
what I'm saying about like make content
for the platform and you understand the
kind of content that could work on Tik
Tok and I would also say here's a real
good hack for all of you selling
something in that range post like crazy
organically and when something goes
viral turn that creative into an ad I
call that brand formance you're doing
brand but the second the world told you
like I like this video you retake it and
you turn it into an you know you almost
turn it into QVC not a TV show like you
tweak it a little bit with a call to
action and hard right hitting like bye
byebye and that will do extremely well
perfect yeah we've had some content on
Tik Tok that's doing well organically so
that's why I was gearing towards that
that meta ads meta ads crushed that
platform's so [__] advanced and
Facebook specifically cuz you have a
older demo that has a higher propensity
to buy but Tik Tok the ads the videos
that have gone well take them out again
tweak them with a call to action put a
price overlay it's okay to turn it into
an ad and rerun it as an ad I think
you'll be
surprised this Market is completely
untapped right and I've tried a bunch of
different ways to penetrate it and I
haven't been able to do it and I'll
explain how I've tried right
so I W this the way how do you define
the market how do I Define the market
what oh the market yeah sorry parents of
those with autistic children and ADH
children with ADHD right um so
essentially when this whole thing
started I was 16 joined like this uh
shark tank for high school and I had
20,000 competitors we won so then from
there we got like this patent and had
and then it immediately took on this
like own world when it comes to like
media success from like local news to
People magazine and 6 months to ABC
Inside Edition and it just kept going
for like a year and a half which is
awesome you know glory to God but the
thing was that um all our sales came
from like publicity and then once that
went away I really didn't have the
skills to be able to sense create the so
we're still like pre-revenue you know
what I mean makes makes a lot of sense
it's a common story okay yeah like you
know media coverage happens all the time
there's always a Feelgood story there's
always something that the media wants to
put at the end of a they they scare you
to death for 49 minutes and tell you how
world is horrible and then they tell you
like a kid's got a chocolate business at
the end you know so and to your point
that [__] can pop off and you can get a
lot of sales but to your point if you
don't build actual sustainable
infrastructure you don't have a business
exactly and that's what that's kind of
what I ran into like and you don't even
know that the first go around you just
think it's going to go forever and it
and it kept going it was so and a year
when you're when you're this young is
like a lifetime it was like it was
honestly like 2 and a half cuz it was
all a the rest of high school and then
but then did you become addicted to that
thing did you like think the only way
like did you at some point realize [__]
I need more press I need more press cuz
that became the drug yeah so I was like
it was it wasn't a drug but it was more
you know what I mean right I I don't
have any other way there's no other way
I'm going to sell [__] so I was like I
guess I just got to keep finding let me
just email the newscaster [__] should
I hire a PR compan like I get it like
one of my one of my this is why I so
[__] with social yeah because the one
thing you can control it's like working
out like there's a lot of [__] you can't
control you can control how you can work
out same with social media like you
can't control People magazine wants to
[__] with you yeah you can control if
you make a Tik Tok yeah so I remember
like it got it get to a point so one of
my um Advisory board members I don't
know if you know him his name is it's
like an informal Advisory Board member
but uh Jamie simov M found a ring I went
to him and I was like hey this press is
going out I don't know how it's against
sales do you have anyone I know and he's
like dude you got to build that
infrastructure you got to work hard you
know so for the last like year and a
half I've been just trying to different
ways right so we went from occupational
therapists and like abas which they work
directly with children with autism ADH
I'm just I'm just making sure that we
don't run a Time next me I'm going to
make sure you have your full 10 keep
going apprciate it um so then I tried
that like a B2B to C route yep and it it
hasn't really panned out I Tred cuzz my
thought process was go to where the
market is right so like it's like
website tassium worldwide.com
so then I was like okay um you know
maybe the thing is that we've sold over
2,000 products with this press and
everyone loves the product it's just
trying to get it into you know the right
people's hands so like I said Trad V BC
we tried nonprofits but they didn't want
to work with us cuz we weren't donating
anything so then we started donating a
little bit but it's just we can't
sustain that when we're pre-revenue my
my keep going keep going so we tried
that um I tried organic um you know with
my story and everything and it it only
went so far and I'm sure if I like kept
going it probably would work um but but
I think that's what that's like what
most like that moment that just happened
Y is everything I give a [__] about I
know I know you know all four of you
probably know right school you know you
but bro it's the [__] game like like
when I go to your website and it's not
clickable to the Tik Tok even though the
logo is down there like that's on my
mind this goes back to the [__]
details even back to working out now
that I've learned a little bit about it
like there's a right way to do a [__]
push-up and there's a wrong way there's
a right way to do a curl and there's
like and this is like how meticulous I
get too back to the proper device you
were getting this [__] M like bro it's
real simple you're in e-commerce MH
you're trying to sell [__] trying to
sell a shirt with an attached thing yeah
you need to do unlimited social media
content so people become aware of it and
then they need to go to a proper webs
like you know where like the shop is
like this shop is not maximized to sell
the most stuff all that's right and
that's okay back to like [__] man I was
[__] really good at business all your
guys ages and like this these gray hairs
you see now like I'm way better now and
so but but for complete Clarity like
when you all go downstairs and be like
okay what the [__] just happen in that
10 what so quick here's the clarity you
are selling [__] when you have unlimited
money or any money yes in 2023 September
7th 2023 and you are trying to sell [__]
yeah the number one thing on earth is
organic social media at scale cuz it's
[__]
free and I mean like 19 posts a day yeah
or you're stuck in the spot that you're
in now which is you're begging for a
[__] miracle that someone's going to
give you cash yeah
yeah and just pitch competitions with
that money Runs Out
if you flipped it and just understood
you're 100% in control [__] a
competition MH [__] a VC [__] everybody
like it was like an Eminem like I like
it was do em SL [__] a papa if you just
understand that you're fully in control
and you just have to pound social yeah
and start googling how to make the best
Shopify site selling T-shirts enter mhm
literally that [__] is out there yeah
for free best practices get the proper
Shopify get your Social Crazy M and
start [__] you know start [__] D
like like life's crazy You Were Here on
a thing I decided I felt something we
have 10 minutes you gave your I'm
literally going to wear this [__]
humble hat I'm so happy and like your
friend's going to be like what like by
the way that's one in 100 and that's
what you need to do you need to [__]
how are you getting back to Boston um
we're taking fairies later beautiful you
need to be on yeah you chop it up and
whatever happened to New York but then
you have to like start dming people in
Boston type in Boston [__] Newton
Mass Boston all that [__] in [__]
Instagram # search top posts click oh
this person's here they have 400,000
followers they're a cool kid in high
school and [__] Newton rich kid and
DM them be like I want you to wear my
[__] shirt one in a 100 of them will
100% but if you [__] like I don't
know like my whole thing is like you
know how I got here by actually doing
what I'm telling you to do when nobody
in the world knew who the [__] I was I
stayed on Twitter in 2007 from [__]
8:00 p.m. after I work the whole day in
the liquor store from 8:00 p.m. to 4:00
in the morning for [__] 4
years every
day yeah you you you have two choices
the luck of cash which is harder than
ever cuz the economy is soft though
you're in a good school where some
things could happen or
sweat I'm not very sweat yeah and I just
think like what most kids are missing
even the ones that are about it and I
genuinely like even if you guys are
sitting here like I wish I was in class
with y'all you know be like chopping it
up like I believe you have it in there I
think this generation and I don't want
to generalize cuz I think there's plenty
of unlimited and you guys may be doing
this but I here's the thing that I think
the world [__] up for y'all when I was
coming up it was like we didn't have
options I when I was in exactly your
seat the internet was just starting so
like you had to like go like work in
this work at like the mall mhm you all
know you can do magic here cuz you've
seen it the problem is 1% of 1% hit the
lottery ticket of it happening fast the
other 10% that make it eat [__] for a
decade but everyone's fixated on the 1%
of the 1% of the 1% who hit something
and even those people
quietly actually had to eat sh for a
little while too m
yeah you're going to start an apparel
brand [__] man it took you know how much
Ronnie ate [__] for how long before kith
mattered yeah rude wasn't overnight yeah
like but it feels that way M so like I
don't know if I'm selling [__]
T-shirt with a hook on the [__] thing
I'm [__] grinding for 10 hours a day
on social media yeah instead of what
you're trying to do which is what
everyone's trying to do is figure out
what to Doh right is doing it yeah
instead of pondering what [__]
competition to apply to lay in bed
listen to your music yeah look at some
girls but then spend 8 hours dming every
single human in Massachusetts saying do
you want a free t-shirt that has 100,000
followers put in their story put that
ask them to put in their story cuz
they're not putting in main Fe anymore
snap shoot it when you [__] see that
they did it put it into your thing
amplify it with $8 cuz that's all you
got in media
ads it's people just lost that yeah cuz
it seems like you can do it the other
way and who wouldn't do it the other way
but that's [__] not real mhm yeah
yeah my dream for for tasting is really
to become like like the Nike for special
needs I get it I heard you loud and
clear I think you can get it I just
think that you have to realize you have
to go into a dark dark [__] cocoon
for the next 5 years and eat straight
[__] it's super real I see everyone
who's popped off and everyone's going to
like everyone's going to think it was
easy it wasn't
mhm tell me tell me which fashion brand
you admire I'll tell you like how many
more movies you want to see about Nike
of how close they went out of business
multiple times before it actually
happened and you know how much luck
Michael Jordan was yeah it was strategy
and the movies will show you but like he
could also torn both his knees MH like
you know what I mean and one would have
been it but Stephon Marberry got hurt on
their sneaker game over M right like
there's just a lot you know what I mean
like bro I at 34 years old I worked in a
liquor
store so of course I'm like what do you
you know of course I'm pumping the [__]
I'm pumping to all y'all patience like
real like eat [__] like cool everybody
wants to tell me but what about this
Gary like the one [__] lucky lottery
ticket go win the lottery
then what about this startup that did it
in 18 months on some [__] Serendipity
of the Stars God's will like you said
like okay cool
somebody won $100 million yesterday in a
lottery ticket you playing you banking
your life on the
lotto so I just don't understand why
people don't get how lucky they have it
I I don't know if I ever would have
worked for my father if I had the
internet that you guys have I probably
wouldn't have made it I would have made
too much money before then but I would
have made too much money because I'm a
dirt kid and even the dirt kids have
become
fancy everybody just thinks it's easier
than it is yeah I appreciate that
[Music]